Oh
you'll get : uh my baby volume down on
this [ __ ] or if I was a smart person
I'll just mute it mute hey how's it
going guys
no assuming that I'm posting this video
way after this event you guys already
know that I went to Hawaii now I go to
Hawaii pretty often and the main reason
why is because that state just reminds
me of calmness and serenity and the
people that are just so nice and
welcoming unlike people in LA you
[ __ ] rude [ __ ] I got robbed
yesterday [ __ ] wasn't cool I'm gonna
tell you something else if I have a see
that 97 year old grandma now a while
back on Bart or Gio's Channel they
announced that they were going to get
married and they also announced that I
was going to be the one that's going to
Wed them now I originally throw that
idea out there but I didn't know how
serious they were about it it turns out
they're pretty [ __ ] serious listen I
hadn't done a wedding in a very long
time and you have to realize that I only
did it on special occasions so of course
what better reason to do it
then for one of my closest friends
possible Bart Gio [ __ ] you I'm [ __ ]
with you I love you Gio you [ __ ] big
Mickey Mouse hand [ __ ] ah it was a very
small party and everybody else came to
Hawaii about a day earlier than I did so
the first thing that we had to do when I
came down was to get rid of all the
paperwork and we went to Hawaii
Department of Health of course tip was
there too because she wanted to be a
part of this joyous moment you know the
funny thing about tip is I think tip was
more excited than Bart and Jill were
about their own marriage you know a few
things that I've gotten to know about
tip is that number one she loves
marriages number two she loves babies
and number three she's extremely
sensitive it's so emotional you love
marriage stuff did I know
I'm just not happy for them because I
know like and I didn't mean anything to
them to me it means a lot it's like
they're it's official like you know
they're officially
like okay more the reason why I'm more
like excited about it because I know the
next step is a baby you sound like you
love babies just like them when they're
newborns not when they start talking but
isn't that the part that most people
hate though I don't mind the lack of
sleep and the constant diaper changing
and the constant being and that's the
craziest thing I ever heard in my life
if you guys ever get the opportunity to
get to know tip you also realized this
girl cries at everything not sad tears
but tears a [ __ ] joy she does this
thing where it seems like she's not
gonna cry but the moment a single word
comes out I just want to say that I love
her girl you said three words before you
broke down and of course after all the
paperwork and all the other [ __ ] was
done the first thing that I wanted to do
was jump in the warm waters of Hawaii
now if you guys admitted the ocean on
the west coast we all know that our
water is cold as [ __ ] the moment
ballsacks touched that water just like a
walnut but Hawaii waters are on a
completely different level they're
extremely warm extremely comforting and
every now and then you might catch some
booty cheeks in that water to your home
fern
you know what in all honesty I had no
idea I caught that footage until I
looked at it later on but thank God
Honolulu I don't know a lot of you
lowlifes comes up there I want to see
the bodies of all the JK girls but let
me tell you something else I'm not that
type of friend I'm [ __ ] lying I am
the type of friend I got plenty of
footage I'll skip just green tea and
patron buddies let's get thrown you will
suck about a foul POTUS [ __ ] he'll let
go though
by my fitness all this [ __ ] I could
do it out o bring a SWAT team if you
walk okay
I know what y'all wanna see your [ __ ]
filthy McNasty yeah that's right
jacking off in the closet to some weird
[ __ ] mmm now TIFF has been working out
super hard to get her body type of
Hawaii so of course I had to do that
special edit for you oh yeah there y'all
give me views you're good though there
you go there you go
I don't you want to see your [ __ ]
filthy McNasty oh one more time you
pervert so you could jack off to it
[ __ ] noise complaint
one day
call a cop
one time at the DOE with that bitch-ass
landlord what they hatin on this photo
[ __ ] no matter I'm putting in that work
go stretch out that buddy then I'll make
that Kitty squirt if just green tea you
put thrown by some buddies let's get
thrown give a [ __ ] about a pop OH - [ __ ]
hella dodo i'ma